how's it going man my name is Pippa
what's up Algie you need my help
no no no whoa nice jump all right how's
it going my name is Pierre well I said
it twice but but you didn't have me the
first time
oh you heard me all right anyway welcome
back to bully which question shall we do
today bras you can pick any one you want
any one you want any quest any question
ado we will the one up there in the dark
ha ha ha you are so good at picking if
you are half as good as picking as you
are beautiful then you are probably like
Leonardo DiCaprio probably if you're
livin out in the cabin [ __ ] and not you
and watching this then please please
give me a kiss because you're beautiful
I'm not gay but that man is gorgeous
ok why the [ __ ] am I going here why
don't you tell me Jase like I have to do
everything here I'm supposed to go over
here that I will thing I'm faster than a
[ __ ] car you know but whoa whoa
whoa bike what the [ __ ] are you doing
here bike I'll take you shut up algae
what's so [ __ ] laughable I don't get
it
all right let's start the nerd quest
here because I am done them in a while
so you know comic klepto nice place
what are you it's beautiful sir are you
okay sorry I like that as a flash never
on his chest just get robbed by a dorky
kid attack I bet my leper Leon okay it's
like hard toy I'll tell you why what
have you five bucks it's a comic if you
help me get my stuff back from that prom
I give you five bucks if he starts
talking normally Jase Jase all right we
got to get this klepto I don't know
where I got the bow
the bike just teleported out of nowhere
but why not complaining
I love teleporting stop stop doing that
your [ __ ] family what the [ __ ] this
guy's crazy punch left punch Right punch
pitter-pat oh not that far oh oh she's
going here damn girl
faint Oh what you gonna do
smells like your mama's nothing huh
get that thing out why come on nipple
twist that [ __ ] never bang man back
it's good he does a lot of damage I
can't [ __ ] with this guy Frank why isn't
the cops helping I run into one person
and the [ __ ] chivalry is coming but
if he even stills there we go
oh you're going down to pier to town oh
that's right much stuff just lying
around
oh that's right mother [ __ ] [ __ ] what
is she doing what oh she's out of breath
now
she ran so far I understand let me take
his bike well this bike is faster
actually whoa nice all right we got to
go back and give a get my five bucks all
right I'm here what's up give me my
comics just give me the money yeah just
give me the money all right
only five bucks you said it give me five
bucks but I get thirty success all right
teach lessons or something I should or I
should just become a stripper honestly
all right so the next quest which one
should I do
Bros the one in school ha ha ha
you keep surprising me with how good you
are at choosing things [ __ ] [ __ ] I
love this bike it's awesome
get out of way
what are the cops doing here crazy crazy
people all right we're gonna go to bed
and dream about bullying and that will
be it
all right cool I hope my bike is still
there it better be bike are you still
hit by huh you are here bike what did
they do to you look at this bike is
awesome
seriously oh sorry man alright so rude
is that a gay couple alright let's open
this gate so I open you know what you
parb stopping a park
sup mouse that's what exactly Wow I'm
the perv
all right paparazzi Hopkins good to see
you big guy quit it now
as our new leader I have something I
need you to do for me no thanks
I mean look do you want to take down the
jocks or what of course I do
yes well I have a plan tell me all about
it well what I need are some
inappropriate pictures of someone they
care about you want pictures yes it's a
complicated plan alright I need some
naughty pictures of that Mandy girl what
does that got to do with this oh this
this is purely for the purposes of this
plan you just want to crap at all you
want me to get incriminating pictures of
the head cheerleader just for your plan
the kind of pictures that could land me
in jail or worse it's not easy being the
boss
uh-huh and this better be good oh it's
fapping material of course it is good
I mean those pixels mm-hmm I haven't
even okay and anyway I guess we're gonna
go and take your paparazzi perb pictures
I don't know if that's the term that or
if I just invented it Farhat superb all
right where is she hiding
all right in the girls
in the girls locker room all right
diggity diggity yeah yeah whoa whoa whoa
whoa
how the hell did I do that this bike
it's the best bike ever
all right that I can jump what the [ __ ]
okay hell yeah let's get up that scared
good photo really that was it that was
[ __ ] it
maybe one day you'll get nice grief
that's oh my god can't wait to get out
of these clothes
who says that who says that all right
all right dig me a lie all right the one
day I want to find a girl I did you
seriously just say that I said I'm not
in class but he's not in class either he
did a cooler bit back sorry but I tried
to break I tried I tried
don't don't please i want to really do
this question aah aah missed me ha ha
that's what you get brows I thought you
[ __ ] yet
are you receiving alien transmissions
well this is listening to that I get
some pictures of Mandy oh it's gonna get
ah [ __ ] [ __ ] sake I literally just went
down no I'm not
can I just beat her literally you drop
off a [ __ ] say uh all I want and all I
ever asked for was pixelated boobs jeez
I don't think I'm done with you
where is she I'm not done with her well
I'm not done with you woman OH
she ran out of breath the [ __ ] is she
doing sir nice is nice Rock she's
running out seriously she's running
outside why did she go even aah aah
all right geography so stupid
I guess who do I bring you down all
right fine one two your seats please
it's a big world we've got to cover
today ah [ __ ]
this is gonna be bad Bros this is gonna
be bad mash the flags to their
correspondent
what what are you serious I know this
one but [ __ ] no else
floor it oh it says all right Florida
good I don't know what town oh [ __ ] I'm
offending somebody Bros here uh [ __ ] me
well I know Obama's in the south right
I'm gonna guess here no I'm sorry that
is incorrect
Oh what the [ __ ] come on I don't know
Kansas Michigan hmm Vegas but I'm afraid
it's wrong that's not Minnesota try
again
yes North Carolina about here try
how about here try again how about here
try again
there we go Nellie New York huh here
right yes I'm not gonna complete South
Dakota hmm try again
that's one try again I hope this isn't
the beginning of a trend ever every
American bro I made them cry now I'm
sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry
if ever I don't have an explanation I
just suck all right J subscribe those
are difficult states I know most
important states like [ __ ] sexism no
I'm not saying the more important
anything out there all in part I love
every States I love so state states a
lot states I seem I seem so ignorant
right now so I'm sorry I'm no more than
those okay no all right so we got to
redo this quest Oh
ah shut up
all right I'm in it no stop you're so
annoying
oh shut up
crisis mode annoying question history of
quests you need Ayana Vick da oh your
[ __ ] alright now get some pics of Mandy
hoola lies in your eating don't get too
close
alright zoom on that [ __ ] how is that a
good photo
I was a least expect my charisma
unpopularity okay no one suspects a
thing when one more picture to take
though get one my picture of the
vajayjay because that's okay with me
this is not weird add on
hahahaha hey guys that's really
unfortunate I love my bras um I don't
know if I have to oh [ __ ]
Oh Kim's good to see you alright I have
to do this quest again this
[ __ ] quest again we're back
here Jesus Christ
alright girl Oh wrap those legs Allah
good father hey what's up that's really
unfortunate it's my face but thank you
oh why would you slap me because of my
eye
why would you do that why don't you trap
me good not [ __ ] come back here I'll
shed it's you against I gotta [ __ ]
slap you Mac Mac come on come on okay
she's tough
wow that [ __ ] is tough Wow no no now
what ah there we go
hope it doesn't make you smell like a
nerd really hello you [ __ ] ah why would
out I [ __ ] hate that [ __ ] but it's
not worth it it's not worth it pills
don't get distracted by your girlfriend
who looks like it has to take a [ __ ]
just get the [ __ ] out of there I'm on my
way you [ __ ] [ __ ] eyebrows I would
just need to fit and fill in this quest
and hopefully we'll be [ __ ] done with
this piece of [ __ ] I can't wait to see
them and fab student
you know they gave me nothing fake money
so much enthusiasm in my dances these
days 25 bucks no work Jimmy
nice work you dick all right we're gonna
go to class now because I feel like I
failed geography so badly that I want I
want to go to class all right what is
this nah
oh oh oh yeah I know I'm [ __ ] [ __ ]
English class we got bad as math going
705 fifth day all right a sex how many
triangles
no what is the smallest Abay 12 equals
this one which is the biggest the planet
which is the lowest this one hello
and that was a pie slow as I 120 this
one Oh what - fastest I know this you
could do better than that
what it's not I don't know I don't even
know what's going on right any more
wrong I lost my touch I lost my true the
rocket I'm gonna squares
I'd say it's five that's half of that
which is mad wow I'm so [ __ ] slow
nine which is the fastest the razor car
sir point five equals that was just a
tallest the pyramids I think which is
the highest every night that is 11
you're not even trying
oops hahaha ah this one I knew it that's
enough for today
yeah I nailed that math class
I made some embarrassing mistakes oh
[ __ ]
you paying attention oh oh person idiot
this has a genius hat excuse me while I
wear my genius hat
all right let's start this quest and
that'll be it for today I want to put on
my genius hat though I'm gonna do that
after this class yes yeah miss Phillip
Jimmy you've interrupted me I'm sorry
good she's not even looking at anything
don't worry about it
can I see sure
take a look it's a penis I think I have
finally caught I know it must be a
banana yes really fun is that guy taking
a [ __ ] about me I've always been more
into music you know why I got taking a
[ __ ] in my thoughts for another really
makes your work glow uh how do you mean
oh she wants me when people do things
incredible things when people blush like
a definition role that really moves me
you know what I mean no I you [ __ ] no
not really
yeah I am in love
Jimmy oh and I want to make tonight very
special Oh would you mind going to
collect a few things while I work my
muse out a dress and perfume she wants
to borrow necklace from the jewelers
what what happened I clicked all I
didn't know that stop stop well we got
to get later please pick up miss
Phillips things excuse
I press we're gonna do that in next
episode I'm gonna have done this in one
anyway I can bear it if you just shut up
what do you silver shirt what did you
say about my shirt BAM